patrick et jocelyne duplain sont les
propriétaires d'un hôtel restaurant à
mesnil saint père et même si la
préfecture de l'aube ne les a pas obligé
ils ont préféré fermer leur
établissement à partir du 15 mars afin
d'entreprendre les aménagements
nécessaires pour accueillir les clients
dans le respect des mesures sanitaires
préconisé en vue d'une réouverture
sauf les spa piscine et espace dufay qui
eux devront rester fermés il y aura à
cet endroit exactement
on va mettre 2e jet de droit alcoolique
donc nos clients à vendre entre et ont
déjà se désinfecter les mains
ensuite tout seul il y aura un marquage
au sol que nous allons essayer de façon
de traiter de façon humoristique et on
va pas mettre des simples bandes de
scotch des trucs comme ça parce que je
pense que dans cette crise où on a été
tous un peu meurtri du confinement avec
des masques avec des jolies visière en
plus que nous allons devoir adapter
ensuite il sera quand est ce assez pour
le personnel qui va être à la réception
nous avons commandé des tenues
spécifiques aussi dû à cette crise
ce qui implique le personnel notamment
nos femmes de chambre quand elles vont
entrer dans notre établissement en tenue
de ville vont nous marquons une douche
se changer mettre leurs uniformes
prendre leur matériel et un matériel qui
est induit pour chaque chambre c'est à
dire qu'à chaque chambre on change de
lavettes on change de tête de lavage
pour les balais donc c'est très
contraignant
il va falloir qu'elle s'adapte je pense
que comme elles auront tout le matériel
n'y a pas de crainte à avoir pour leur
santé ni rien du tout et que nos clients
soient aussi en pleine confiance
quand ils vont réserver dans notre
talent à quelques kilomètres de là à
l'ombre et seul monsieur et madame o
mais sont les gérants de cette maison
d'hôtes depuis cinq ans eux n'ont pas
fermé pendant la crise et les premières
réservations commencent enfin à arriver
mais contrairement à d'autres
établissements ils vont continuer de
servir les petits déjeuners
l'un des attraits conviviaux de ce type
d'hébergement en s'adaptant petit
déjeuner on aura une distanciation
niera toujours présent parce que donc
c'est le côté convivial c'est si là où
on a beaucoup des changes
c'est là où on fait découvrir notre
département si le moment du petit
déjeuner s'est parlé de tout ce qui nous
entoure et ça on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas ne pas le faire c'est c'est un
manque complet par rapport à notre
clientèle qui recherche chez nous
emmenant maison d'hôtes
ils recherchent cherche automatiquement
un contact donc on sera distant bien sûr
on essaiera de prendre la distance qu'il
faut un médecin quand on sera au tour
mais voilà on sera présents des
professionnels qui peuvent compter sur
le soutien du comité départemental du
tourisme de l'aube en champagne ce qui
est réglementaire et puis il y à tous
que le prestataire va pouvoir proposer
en plus et nous nous engageons nos
prestataires à être volontaire dans ces
gestes là parce que le touriste encore
une fois aura des exigences aura des
peurs et il faut répondre à tout cela
donc on veut vraiment faire de ses
gestes
une force dans le territoire et on va
mettre en valeur tout ce que ces
prestataires vont pouvoir proposer donc
nous allons établir un label avec un
outil qui va s'appeler visite for safe
et le principe c'est d'apporter les
garanties de la mise en oeuvre de ses
gestes
nécessaire et pourquoi pas des gestes
volontaires supplémentaires selon les
données du département la baisse du
chiffre d'affaires sur ces deux derniers
mois atteint les 90% pour le secteur
touristique